>>> IT'S MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND
ANEVERYBODY IS GETTING IN THE
POOL.
I'M MICHAEL SMERCONISH IN
PHILADELPHIA.
WHY ARE SO MANY PUBLICAN
CANDIDATES NOW CHALLENGING
DONALD TRUMP FOR THE GOP
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION?
THINK ABOUT IT.
HE'S A FORMER PRESIDENT,
ESSENTIALLY A GOP INCUMBENT,
WHO'S CONSISTENTLY POLLING
AROUND 50% OF THE GOP VOTE IN
THE POLLS.
AND WE LEARNED IN 2016 THAT
GIVEN THE HARD-CORE SUPPORT THAT
TRUMP ENJOYS FROM SOME, HE'S THE
BENEFICIARY OF A LARGE FIELD.
REMEMBER, IN THAT CYCLE THERE
WERE SO MANY RUNNING THAT
DEBATES, THEY HAD A KIDS TABLE.
THIS TIME TRUMP ANNOUNCED FIRST
AND THEN NIKKI HALEY AND THEN
VIVAK, LARRY ELDER, ASA
HUTCHINSON, TIM SCOTT, AND NOW
RON DeSANTIS, WHO BY THE WAY IS
ONLY 44 YEARS OLD.
BY BIDEN/TRUMP STANDARDS, HE'S
GOT THREE MORE DECADES TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
SO WHY RUN NOW?
WHY GET INTO THE STEEL CAGE WITH
A WRESTLER WHO ALWAYS CARRIES A
FOREIGN OBJECT?
MIKE PENCE SAID HE'LL SOON MAKE
A DECISION.
CHRIS CHRISTIE SURE SOUNDS LIKE
A CANDIDATE.
SUNUNU MIGHT GET IN.
EVEN GLENN YOUNGKIN IS TAKING A
SECOND LOOK.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON?
MAYBE THAT THEY DON'T THINK
THEY'LL HAVE TO BEAT TRUMP.
THAT THAT WORK WILL BE DONE BY A
COMBINATION OF ALVIN BRAGG, FANI
WILLIS, JACK SMITH AND MERRICK
GARLAND.
THIS WEEK TRUMP APPEARED
REMOTELY IN A MANHATTAN
COURTROOM IN CONNECTION WITH THE
STORMY DANIELS CASE.
THE JUDGE TOLD THE PARTIES NOT
TO MAKE ANY PLANS AROUND THE
SCHEDULED START OF TRIAL, MARCH
25, 2024.
TRUMP REPORTEDLY REACTED BY
SHAKING HIS HEAD.
THERE'S STILL JOCKEYING GOING ON
REGARDING THE CAUCUS AND PRIMARY
SCHEDULE FOR NEXT YEAR, BUT TAKE
A LOOK AT 2016.
THAT WAS THE LAST TIME THAT WE
HAD A COMPETITIVE REPUBLICAN
PROCESS.
LOOK AT THAT AS A GUIDE.
IN THAT CYCLE IOWA HELD ITS
CAUCUS ON FEBRUARY 1st.
NEW HAMPSHIRE VOTED ON FEBRUARY
9.
THEN CAME SOUTH CAROLINA AND
NEVADA.
SUPER TUESDAY WAS MARCH 1.
THERE WERE SIX MORE ELECTION
DAYS IN MARCH.
AND THEN IN APRIL CAME
WISCONSIN, NEW YORK,
CONNECTICUT, DELAWARE, MARYLAND,
PENNSYLVANIA, RHODE ISLAND,
INDIANA.
AND IN MAY NEBRASKA, WEST
VIRGINIA, OREGON AND WASHINGTON
STATE.
IN THE THICK OF THAT SCHEDULE,
DONALD TRUMP WILL SPEND A WEEK
OR TWO SITTING IN A MANHATTAN
COURTROOM FACING CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
AND EVEN WITHOUT CAMERAS IN NEW
YORK COURTROOMS, HIS COMINGS AND
GOINGS WILL ALL BE NOTED.
SKETCH ARTISTS WILL HAVE A FIELD
DAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE O.J. ON
STEROIDS.
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
LAST MONTH FULTON COUNTY D.A.
FANI WILLIS SENT A LETTER TO THE
COUNTY'S SHERIFF PUTTING HIM ON
NOTICE OF CHARGING DECISIONS
THAT SHE'LL ANNOUNCE IN
CONNECTION WITH HER
INVESTIGATION OF GEORGIA'S 2020
ELECTION.
SHE WROTE THESE WORDS.
I'M PROVIDING THIS LETTER TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION THE NEED
FOR HEIGHTENED SECURITY AND
PREPAREDNESS IN THE COMING
MONTHS.
SHE NOTED HER TIMETABLE WAS
BETWEEN JULY 11 AND SEPTEMBER 1.
NOW, GRANTED THERE ARE MORE
INDIVIDUALS THAN JUST DONALD
TRUMP WHOSE CONDUCT IS BEING
INVESTIGATED IN GEORGIA.
BUT WOULD ANY OF THE OTHERS
WARRANT NOTIFICATION OF THE
SHERIFF?
OF THE POSSIBILITY OF UNREST?
I DOUBT IT.
INSTEAD, I THINK SHE TIPPED HER
HAND THAT SHE INTENDS TO INDICT
HIM.
AND THEN THERE'S SPECIAL COUNSEL
JACK SMITH APPOINTED BY MERRICK
GARLAND.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" WAS
THE FIRST TO REPORT THIS WEEK
THAT SMITH HAS ALL BUT FINISHED
HIS WORK.
THEY REPORTED IN RECENT WEEKS
PROSECUTORS WORKING FOR SMITH
HAVE COMPLETED INTERVIEWS WITH
NEARLY EVERY EMPLOYEE AT TRUMP'S
FLORIDA HOME, FROM TOP POLITICAL
AIDES TO MAIDS AND MAINTENANCE
STAFF.
"THE JOURNAL" COULDN'T DETERMINE
WHETHER SMITH HAS DECIDED TO
CHARGE TRUMP.
BUT EARLY THIS WEEK TRUMP'S
LAWYERS SOUGHT A MEETING WITH
MERRICK GARLAND.
COMMON SENSE SUGGESTS THERE'S NO
NEED FOR A MEETING UNLESS
TRUMP'S LAWYERS THINK HE'S ABOUT
TO BE INDICTED.
AND NOW "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTS THAT TWO OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S EMPLOYEES MOVED
BOXES OF PAPERS FROM WITHIN HIS
MAR-A-LAGO HOME A DAY BEFORE FBI
AGENTS AND A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL ARRIVED TO PICK UP
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
SO THERE'S A SERIOUS PROSPECT OF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SOON FACING
CRIMINAL CHARGES IN THREE
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS AND IN
THE THICK OF THE CAMPAIGN.
SOME WILL SUGGEST THAT THIS IS
ALL TO TRUMP'S BENEFIT.
ACCORDING TO HIS CAMPAIGN, HE
BENEFITED FINANCIALLY AFTER
ALVIN BRAGG CHARGED HIM IN THE
STORMY DANIELS CASE RAISING
$15.4 MILLION IN TWO WEEKS AND
HIS POLLS WENT UP.
I THINK BECAUSE AT ITS ROOT,
THAT'S A CASE ABOUT SEX.
AND IN THE 1990s WE LEARNED THAT
AMERICANS DON'T SEE THAT AS
WARRANTING A PRESIDENTIAL
DOWNFALL.
BUT WOULD ADDITIONAL
PROSECUTIONS HAVE THE SAME
IMPACT?
WOULD SOME HAVE ENOUGH OF THE
REALITY SHOW?
I CAN THINK OF SEVERAL IN THE
LATTER CAMP.
THEIR NAMES ARE HALEY,
HUTCHINSON, SCOTT, DeSANTIS,
MAYBE PENCE, CHRISTIE, SUNUNU,
AND YOUNGKIN TOO.
AND IF THEY'RE RIGHT AND TRUMP
ISN'T THE CANDIDATE, DOES THAT
PUT MORE PRESSURE ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO STEP ASIDE SHOWING THAT
EVEN DEMOCRATS WANT A CHANGE IN
THEIR TICKET.
HIS RETORT IS TO SUGGEST THAT